[Music]
so what we're going to look at is how to
engage more users on Android TV and earn
more revenue on Android TV and look at
all the new features around Android TV
and all the things that we're doing with
it
so a quick overview of the topics for
today's discussion first we're going to
look at what we're doing is Android and
Google Play in the living room and our
overall strategy around that then we're
going to look at the importance of
having a really really good TV strategy
and why that's important for your
business and then finally we're going to
look at specific ways where where you
can drive engagement and grow revenue so
that third bullet that's the most
important juicy part so stay stay until
then so to begin we're going to take you
all the different things that we're
doing with Android and Google Play and
walk you through a little update of our
business and walk you through of all the
new announcements that we've made
recently here at i/o and in previous
months from there so taking a step back
we look at how Android has evolved we
started off with phones we expand it to
tablets we moved to watches cars and TVs
and we went into virtual reality
headsets and the concept behind it is
one unified platform for our developers
to build on and to easily interact with
their audiences on so when we think
about this platform how do we distribute
content well Google play's the
consistent place where you can
distribute our content one interface
it's consistent for your audiences and
one developer console where you can push
out all of your updates and all the
different things that you need to do
within it so how do we think about our
living room strategy well to be honest
there are many form factors and the
reason that we do this is we want to
make sure that different people have
exactly what they need so when we think
about how we discuss this with our
developers
we tell developers you can create one
app for both experiences that will vary
for our users who have different needs
and different ways that they can get
content into living room so when we
think about Android TV we have a deeper
experience we think of use of remote
control native elements to navigate and
content is searchable in a TV UI
similarly when we think about chromecast
you take your existing app you take a
simpler interface and you easily push
that content onto the big screen it's
available both on iOS and Android so
when we think about that livings from
strategies you have an Android app you
can turn that Android app into a TV app
you can supplement that Android app into
a cast-enabled app this is something for
everyone and something for everyone's
different viewing habits so the focus of
this talk is Android TV so we want to
take a quick first step back to tell you
how we've extended Android TV into the
living room so Android TV initially
launched which is Nexus player back at
the end of November 2014
it helps expand Android into the living
room with that we use that exact same
reference across all of our different
OEMs to deliver a successful UX
different hardware for OEMs for
different people depending on their
choice just like we initially had for
phone and tablet and again the Play
Store was there and all of our great
Play apps and our Google apps were all
within there so all of the elements for
Android we're hitting the big screen so
as we've gone through this journey
there have been partnerships with some
of the top global brands in the world
across different countries and across
multiple form factors our ecosystem is
really focused on three different areas
first we have Smart TVs then we have
streeting players and then we have
operators so we have some of the
partnerships of some of the top OMS in
each vertical as you see here sony is a
big partner on our Smart TV side eros is
another one in our streaming player
set-top box that we initially announced
and sling TV and dish network is another
one that we announced last at CES
and there's many others that are coming
20 of our top operators will be
launching later in 2017 so one of the
things that you heard about in the
keynote was the growth of Android TV so
Android TV activations over the last 12
months have more than doubled on a
year-over-year monthly average and we
have 1 million activated Android TVs for
every 60 days so a lot of this growth is
attributed to the great OEMs that have
come on this plot come on our platform
and it distributed the platform for us
and with that we have a number of great
apps for every type of user personally I
love sports so we recently had ESPN and
NFL joining our ecosystem of apps but we
have others from European apps like
canal to news apps like CNBC and 3,000
plus apps across the ecosystem that
we're very very proud of for our
developer partners to bring thank you
such so thank you as you can see it's
been a great year for Android TV and
moving forward Google will continue to
invest in his different living room
solutions since we launched Android TV
three years ago and we've also seen that
the user are becoming more and more
demanding when it comes to their TV
experience they expect TV Everywhere
with likes index access to their
accounts on all their device they also
like excite high quality content with 4k
resolution they expect the ability to
get that content anytime with on-demand
services but this tells us also that TV
still continues playing an essential
role essential role when it comes to how
people consume media content among
others here are a number of reason why
we believe that TV should be at the
center of your strategy so first of all
while mobile viewing are growing
exponentially we also see that TV still
dominates when it comes to lean back
experiences
studies from statisti in 2016 so that
average user interaction time is three
times higher on TV than it is on
smartphone in other words TV has a
unique ability to engage deeply with
your users with longer session length
and these statistics are confirmed with
the performance of Google Play Movies on
Android TV if you look at Google Play
Movies in 2016 the average session
length were 2.5 times higher on Android
TV than they were on smartphone more
interestingly you look at the average
revenue per user it was 5 times higher
on Google Play Movies on Android TV than
it is on smartphone so we've seen that
TV gives longer interactions higher
revenue per user but it also influenced
positively retention this data shared by
Netflix
compared the importance of different
form factors at signup and after six
months and what it tells us is really
interesting to me while 80% of the
acquisition takes place outside of TV TV
becomes the primary device for 2/3 of
the users after 6 months according to
Netflix the usage of a living room
device directly translates into an
increase in retention and obviously
lifetime value this means that for you
early on very early in the user journey
you need to encourage and promote the
activation of a living room device in
order to increase and increase your
lifetime value great now now that we've
gone through the various reasons why you
should have an important living room
strategy we're going to look at ways
that you can specifically improve
engagement on on Android TV and one of
the big announcements that we've made
recently is Google assistant is coming
to Android G TV as you've heard from IO
this week Google assistants very very
important to Google
every single one of our products is
being touched with Google assistant we
believe specifically on TV this brings a
new opportunity to increase engagement
and bring your best content right in
front of your users we are going to show
you all the capabilities that come with
assistant on TV and what makes it a
unique opportunity to brew improve
discoverability and as a result the
engagement with your content
so beyond connecting people to
information the assistant would also
help a wide range of our developers
complete many kind of actions for users
that will occur across contexts and
devices any assistant should be able to
help you in two-way waves just do what
you need with direct actions or connect
you to an expert with conversation
actions so what we've done with Google
assistant is we've built on 17 years of
history of helping our users the
assistant is made for our user their own
Google it has four elements
conversational personal fast and fun the
Google assistant allows you to talk or
text from Google in the natural length
think of it as you're having a
conversation with Google in order to
help you get things done in your own
world so before we dive in on the
details of assistant with TV we want to
discuss the core of this product inter
integration is your content feed which
works not just on assistant but across
all of your services we hope that our
development partners will maximize their
content reach across all services and
products that enable our consumers to
engage with this content by taking one
feed of catalog metadata and
merchandising we will see the experience
that provides the following four things
a consistency of search across all
Google products and services visibility
as an option for content titles
available across all these multiple
services that you see here customized
availability of the metadata for content
available on a specific service and
merchandising across all these multiple
platforms and products you'll see here
that the reach goes across assistance
Android TV the Google home app
and search results as well that one feed
populates all of these different
surfaces which your which your users
touch Google on so how does this relate
specifically to Android TV well
assistant allows you to do three things
on TV first you have discoverability
assistant on TV is all about content and
control by searching using assistant on
TV users can find their favorite shows
and some services with a simple ok
Google show me sci-fi shows and suddenly
you'll see all the difference that
sci-fi shows that are available across
all of your different apps secondly you
have engagement so once you have an app
that is already installed assistant is a
great way to re-engage the audience by
invoking very specific shows to play and
content that lives within your apps
pick your favorite shows ask a system to
play it and get ready to watch ok Google
continue watching put your favorite
shows name in there finally assistant
gives you control on TV you want to give
you users the most that they can do in
control so by using a media session API
to make easier playback control you can
say things like ok Google pause playback
or ok Google go back five minutes or
even more informational things such as
ok Google when does this air so in order
to do this integration we have two
specific parts part one is transport
controls for voice control of playback
and then part two is metadata for
assistance intelligent responses thank
you so as we saw thanks to a more
natural voice integration Google
assistant will allow you to improve how
your user will discover and engage with
your content
but there's another update on Android TV
and for those who are the keynotes on
Wednesday we were really excited to
announce the launch of the new Android
TV home experience this new Android TV
is
Faye's will be available on all Android
TV device that will upgrade to all
starting this summer so let's take a
look at it and before I jump in to
decide how many of you here have an
Android TV app okay so you're not just
here because it's too hard that's good
and how many of you are just thinking
about building one okay so it's already
convinced people okay good so you
probably familiar with this interface
which like a lot of other device like
streaming device in the market is what
we call app centric which means that
really the app are their center of the
experience but since we launched Android
TV three years ago we realized that
things were changing and user were like
consuming entertainment differently in
the living room well of course then we
realized that the user gets more and
more content they have more and more
content available and it's increasingly
difficult for them to make a decision on
what to watch we have to compare content
sources from live TV to advert to TiVo
to UGC and also compile compares content
providers go into the apps browse the
content dwell out and change provider
that's increasingly different it is
difficult this is why with Android oh we
are completely redefined the experience
on the home screen of Android TV we made
it channel based but more importantly we
made it content centric this means that
we're giving more and more prominence to
the control your content in the
discovery experience we basically want
the user to spend more time watching
your content as opposed to simply like
looking for it not only we think that
this will significantly improve
discovery we also think that this will
impact positively the way you're going
to re-engage with your user to get them
to come back to your app and and watch
your content so let's take a closer look
at it so the top you have quick access
to the search functionality which now
becomes Google as distant as Serge was
explaining
just below you have the favorite a pro
which basically allow user to launch
into your their up their favorite up
really quickly on the left you can see
on the right sorry red bottom which is
basically the app view page which sort
of includes all the apps that are
installed into the device but here's
when it becomes interesting
continuing down you have like several
roles that we call channels these
channels are made of cards that we call
programs it basically gives maximum
prominence to your content these
channels are the core of the new home
screen experience each developer will be
able to create his own channel and
benefit from a great greater real estate
to promote their content
when a user select one program well
obviously be it launches the ads and
immediately start the playback but
interestingly if the user decides to
press the back button instead of coming
back to the home page of Android TV it
will be taken to a higher level screen
of your app and continue browsing within
your own app as a developer of course
you have full control of what you put in
your channel you can decide what content
you're going to put what programs you
put what order you want to do to show
them all the content metadata as well as
the channel names and the branding one
of the features are more excited about
is video previews that are played as you
can see here that are plays whenever one
particular program is on focus as a
developer as a developer you can decide
what to include in this video preview
like live TV either trailers or kind of
videos video previews by default only
one primary channel will be displayed
into the Android TV interface but as a
developer you can decide to add add
additional channels that user will be to
will be able to kind of add into their
interface according to their preferences
so let's say you are for example a paid
TV provider and you create your primary
channel that aggregates all
the best content you have you can also
think about creating additional
secondary channels based on like
specific topics like sports kit contents
or series that the user will be able to
add into his interface according to his
preferences so as mentioned earlier
Android TV is of course about discovery
the new laundry TV home is about
discovery but it's also a lot about
reengagement we really want to make sure
that your user it can come back to your
app in consuming to the consume their
content again and again this is why we
created what we call the watch next role
all the content that the user has been
in previously engaged with will be
consolidated aggregated into this watch
next channel that will always appear in
second positions below the favorite app
role
studies show that a large majority of
watch sessions are linked to previously
engage content and this is like the
whole thinking around it as a developer
this will help you drive re-engagement
and improve your retention as your
content will be seen in this channel
whenever for example a user of the play
the video and doesn't finish it or a new
episode of a series is newly available
or just simply because the user could
have added your content into the watch
list so in the previous two sections we
gave you another view of the most recent
evolution of android TV if you think
about it both Google assistance and the
new Android TV home screen aims at
improving discoverability of the content
but more importantly reengagement longer
term with your existing customers but
beyond these two platform the evolutions
that there are a lot of things that you
can do inside your app in order to
improve the experience remember as a
form factor TV is a unique in the way we
interact with you with it that the use
of a remote control make it often quite
tedious and difficult to kind of
navigate this means that you should pay
even more attention
- kind of making sure that the
experience is as frictionless as
possible
it's each critical point of your user
journey
so typically identification discovery
and payment so let's start with
identification while identification is a
obviously a precondition for the
personalization of your experience
inside of your app it's also a critical
moment where developers like do you lose
a lot of users that's why we introduced
a couple of years ago smart local
passwords in order to remove this
friction so by integrating with smart
lock for passwords you can automatically
sign up users into your app using the
credentials that they have already saved
on other Android device on Chrome so in
this example with my channel there has
automatically recognized and logged in
the user that was accessing the app for
the first time this is especially
relevant knowing that as we said doing
the identification process on TV with a
remote control is particularly painful
so now let's talk about discovery as we
all know discovery is a very complex
process that involve internal external
factors that will determine what the
user wants to watch but also how precise
is the idea of what I wanna watch so if
you're commuting it wasn't only dislike
similar to you if you are nicely
comfortably sitting on your sofa how
much time do you have how many people
are part of the watching group you mood
and your mindset at a particular time we
did determine directly the discovery and
position you differently in what we call
this set and free spectrum so across the
industry
we shall research tells us that when
deciding deciding what to watch user
operates in four different modalities
find select browse and serve often
people can jump from one modality to the
other like as soon as for example some
content finishes or
a new person comes into the watching
group etc but the goal for you is to
make sure that your app address each of
these modalities with a minimum effort
so let's start with search we estimate
that around 20% of the viewing comes
from a search functionality but that
makes that means that you should really
has real value for you to kind of make
sure that this works beyond content in
titles you should make sure that the
search functionality always also takes
into account all your metadata such as
actors categories jars etc etc are you
able to address and solve queries we
realize like a lot of users are making
queries that actually don't lead to any
results there is something to be done
around it also could you improve the
search experience using what we call
natural language processing in order to
make the experience even more kind of
natural similarly make sure that the
user has the ability to access his
favorite content with functionality such
as DVR watch list or add to favorites
and moving down to the the certain sea
spectrum there are different ways to
inspire your users so they can find
their content the usage of kind of most
popular collection content categories or
etc etc and even like more editorial
collection that can really inspire a
user and what to watch so think about
all these different modalities I think
within Europe what you can do in order
to address each of them so once the user
shows some interest in a particular
content you want to make sure that he
also has access to all the relevant
information that would help me take the
decision to actually watch this content
so of course title goes so a short and
long descriptions don't undermine the
importance of beautiful images and video
trailers
finally third-party ratings review I
also like critical when it comes to
taking a decision another aspect that I
find interesting is this idea of making
you experience even more linear inside
your app so the benefits of on-demand
consumption is undeniable people are no
longer forced to come back to their
house version 2 they're kind of living
room to watch their favorite program
they can just take their replay and
on-demand service in watch it
however we believe that users still love
what linear TV has to offer if you turn
out your TV you can be passive you get
some movie images you enjoy the
serendipity of kind of discovery and you
also enjoy the free DT of the experience
as a result as an on-demand content
provider you should think about all the
way you can recreate certain aspects of
this kind of linear experience by adding
functionality such as watch next that
are famously at the origin of binge
watching related content but also
picture-in-picture and background
playing and animated carousel all these
functionalities really makes the
experience within your apps linear again
last but not least obviously payments
with the rise of Millennials and cold
cutters many media partners have
launched their own work called direct to
consumer experiences and studies which
means that now all these partners at
least you going to handle the payments
directly as mentioned earlier more than
in any other form factor friction on TV
can be prohibitive being such a critical
step of your user journey you really
want to make sure that payment is
handled correctly and is as simple as
possible by integrating with Google Play
dealing user can complete their payments
in only 3 clicks
they can benefit from having already
there kind of details saving to the
account and benefit from having the
different option in terms of form of
payments getting credit cards PayPal and
DCB subscription is a huge opportunity
for subscribers and over the last year
with double on in Google Play with
double our revenue associated to
subscription as a consequence we've
multiplied the number of useful tools
and functionality inside the console in
order to manage for you this
subscription subscription dashboard that
was presented yesterday flexible payment
periods and of course promotional tools
that includes intra pricing and pre
trial all these aspects should again
remove the friction within the tip
expands to execute the payment all right
well thank you for taking the time to
attend our talk today hopefully you've
learned a couple of things and we showed
you a little bit of how to achieve
success on Android TV but before we jump
into the questions we wanted to leave
you with a few key takeaways around our
talk so first we explored how Android
and play can empower our living room
strategy through an overview of the
platform and how we are positioned to
succeed with the growth of the ecosystem
of both Android and our OEMs and play in
our app developers we showed you how
having the right living room strategy is
important for app success we showed you
how this strategy shapes deeper
interactions higher retention and
improved lifetime value finally we
showed you some of the best practices
that we recommend to drive engagement
and grow revenue some examples of these
integrations were for Google Assistant
Android o for content discovery
frictionless signup and other various
user experiences in your app so thank
you for coming and as we'll take some
questions down
[Applause]
[Music]